[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros y
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el pasado
sábado 28 de noviembre el papá francisco
llevó a cabo un consistorio una
ceremonia para la creación de 13 nuevos
cardenales estos nombramientos son
cruciales para la iglesia católica ya
que son los cardenales quienes
participan en el cónclave y los menores
de 80 años votan para elegir al próximo
papá entre los nuevos cardenales de este
año hay un mexicano el ex obispo de san
cristóbal de las casas en chiapas
monseñor felipe arizmendi esquivel
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en las afueras del vaticano con
todo gusto es un placer estar con
ustedes que señales están guiando
francisco con su nombramiento piensa que
es un reconocimiento al mundo indígena
al cual usted ha estado tan ligado a lo
largo de su vida
algunos han interpretado este
nombramiento del papá como un apoyo a la
pastoral indígena
yo considero que el trabajo que yo he
hecho no lo he hecho yo solo lo hemos
hecho muchísima gente yo les he dicho a
muchos indígenas que hemos compartido
estos días que este nombramiento es para
ellos y por ellos porque sin ellos yo
que he hecho nada me había tocado
coordinar apoyar animar pero ellos son
los que más trabajan entonces es un
reconocimiento para tanta gente que da
la vida por los indígenas su
nombramiento se produce en un momento en
el cual la iglesia católica en américa
latina afronta el avance de las iglesias
evangélicas esto es una amenaza para el
catolicismo en latinoamérica más que
verlos como una amenaza yo lo veo como
un apoyo también vamos trabajando juntos
todos vamos trabajando por el señor y
por ren por méxico todos nos reunimos
cada cuatro meses los obispos de chiapas
con los líderes de los adventistas
presbiterianos bautistas mormones
asambleas de dios buen pastor nazarenos
y otros más y veíamos no discusiones
teológicas sino que podemos hacer por la
comunidad que podemos ser los jóvenes
por la familia por chiapas por la paz
por la reconciliación
este es el séptimo año que el papá
francisco nombra un nuevo grupo de
cardenales desde su elección en 2013 que
impronta está dejando francisco con
estos nombramientos está desplazando el
equilibrio de poder en la iglesia desde
europa hacia el mundo en desarrollo
hacia las periferias un poco hacia
américa latina qué opina usted de esto
las periferias no son para despreciar
las y solamente para ayudarles yo
también pueden aportar los pobres los
indígenas las periferias no solamente
indígenas sino también las periferias de
las ciudades que a veces sufren más que
los indígenas tienen que aportar al
centro al centro no solamente de roma'
no solamente al centro que es europa
sino al centro de la humanidad y el
centro de la humanidad no es a europa
los centros de la humanidad está en el
corazón de cada persona pero las
llamadas periferias si podemos aportar
algo a la iglesia universal usted viene
de méxico un país que ha sido
fuertemente sacudido por la crisis de
los abusos sexuales a menores cometidos
por miembros del clero cómo piensa usted
ejercer el poder que va a tener como
cardenal de la iglesia católica para
ganar
que estos crímenes no se van a repetir y
que los culpables serán castigados nunca
más debe aparecer este crimen tan
vergonzoso de la pederastia clerical eso
es un crimen abominable y
afortunadamente la iglesia a nivel
universal y a nivel local ya se han dado
muchos pasos para prevenir esto desde la
prevención los seminarios saber escoger
los candidatos y después a seguir la
formación permanente de los sacerdotes y
se están dando pasos afortunadamente yo
creo que ya de la crisis que tuvimos con
el padre marcial maciel ya esa crisis ya
pasó ahora faltan otros ahora el
problema es grave es la inseguridad la
violencia el narcotráfico algunos lo
describen a usted como progresista lo
social y conservador en temas de
doctrina
hace poco el papá francisco causó
revuelo mediático con declaraciones en
las cuales abogó por las uniones civiles
para parejas del mismo sexo qué opina
usted de esto quiero vivir el evangelio
de acuerdo con el evangelio
y el evangelio que ma nos enseña es que
dios ama a todos incluso a los que
pudiéramos considerar pecadores y no
podemos dudar juzgar a nadie
los dios ama a todos sea homosexuales
sean asesinos dios ama a todos y la
iglesia tiene que amar a todos no
significa estar de acuerdo con lo malo
no pero significa son personas y como
personas merecen todo nuestro respeto y
nuestro apoyo nuestra atención mil
gracias cardenal por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en esta entrevista y a
ustedes televidentes gracias por su
atención
continúen con nosotros aquí
[Música]